hello sir he is gene Simmons and he's
looking very rock and roll today leather
vest yes not upstairs
how are you soul eriously hi oh now
you're serious not happens usually it's
just jokes and that not come on you do
an Audrey metal stuff but nothing today
it's like Jean how are you well he's
running the show now I know I have to be
responsible and you lost your job was
giving you a fist bump Jim you're not
fist bumping gene Simmons why didn't
hello I thought it was a germaphobe big
bump on I'm not I just don't want to get
caught cats cold actually truthfully I
stopped shaking hands and not that I'm a
German forward I think but I won't take
dick in my mouth but otherwise that's
where you and I part company but I
stopped doing it and I haven't been sick
in five years literally I mean when you
think about so what do you doing
meet-and-greets when they want to shake
your hand you just four thousand dollars
fourteen hundred fifty thousand dollar
version of the gene Simmons vault where
you go to their house am i that's
incorrect let's actually fake news none
of that's true tell me what's the deal I
will if you don't suck up the oxygen
from the rooms so here's what's gonna so
there's a largest box set of all time
called the gene Simmons vault dot-com so
you go to gene simmons Volcom you'll
find out inside is 50 years of
unreleased tracks from 1966 in the 20th
century all the way to 2016 why are they
unreleased well I'm just a busy guy and
I'm sure there are clothes in your
closet you never wore not me I am but I
don't have a vault full of clothes
either you're okay Rob so that's what
I'm talking about me Yeah right
slightly Sam's not about you in your
closet Mary's right he's more eclectic
than but he came out of there oh that's
good he's still in tunes that have never
been released over the years from 66
until 2016 some of the songs are Cora
with Bob Dylan they're in there
actual songwriting experience of Bob and
I just strumming away and doing stuff
that's in there
I found van Halen three tracks were
playing together the van Halen brothers
and I that's in there Joe Perry playing
on [ __ ] man from 1978 which I wrote
it's in their old original versions of
calling dr. love Christine sixteen all
those things are all in there tons and
tons of stuff but what nobody has ever
done which I can afford to do and
because I want to give back to the fans
now that kisses the number one American
gold record award winning group of all
time in all categories is I'm gonna pay
for myself to get on jets and go around
the world and I will hand deliver every
single vault to anyone who buys it they
go for two grand
two iPhones will get you gene Simmons
flying to New Zealand or Zimbabwe or
wherever you get it we have to find a
convenient time obviously it's got to be
more than one of you buying it otherwise
you know I'll go poor before you will
because you're a rich son of a [ __ ]
aren't you I do okay I might be rich but
I'm okay all right everybody's never
been married so he hasn't lost any of
his money no okay
that helps that was today's he's yeah
he's never been married his lifestyle
only recently has allowed him to be
married yes so Jim is straight Jim is
Jim is he's a gender-fluid that for many
people but from you our product
tolerance so any question about these
this stuff you do but then hey Lynn with
Bob Dylan was that originally supposed
to go on like kiss records or is that
supposed to be solo stuff or is that
supposed to be on Bob's no because I
don't drink and don't get high and do
any of that stuff so I'm always every
day is busy and there are literally
hundreds of tunes I've written over the
years and extra books that have never
been published and but I keep everything
you do so there was no intention for
ending its just linear you go along the
road and pick up stuff and you do stuff
and then later on you're trying to
figure out who what when where and how
right but you just you do the work when
you have an opportunity to do it figure
what like when I had time I wrote
another book
so there's another book waiting in the
wings I there's another magazine coming
up called mogul which I'm sure there's a
I got hired by McLaren the car company
and Michael's the hobby store come ended
you don't have enough hours in the day
and so it's not linear thinking it's
more you do a lot of stuff and you keep
busy and then you figure out where to
put it and all that but as long as
she'll take off without doing anything
will you'll go like I don't I don't want
to work I just want a vacation I don't
want to I don't want to think about kiss
I don't want to think about like with
this project like what's the longer
she'll give yourself to just kind of do
it I'm 68 do I look good yeah sure do I
was saying that before you came in would
I not yeah that's fully I'm straight Jim
no no me too I mean I say with the flu I
mean I love my gay brothers and sisters
and I was Ruby FC by the fluid part
scared yeah it should be fluid it does
kind of scare it sounds like a physical
thing is you're not sure he's sure
anything yeah Caitlin ish Jim thinks
Marie Kaelin Kim thinks that gender
exists on a spectrum and so you've got
you know in big words in the morning I
know I don't think that I don't know
what you know I said the answer the
answer is I literally haven't taken a
vacation ever I don't why would you like
whatever it is you like eating if you
want to be trapped in a bakery and
stuffing your gourd with jelly rolls and
stuff so when you want to take some time
off
sometimes creatively though like just to
do instead there's times where I like I
get into like the thing will you burn
out and I start almost feeding on myself
and like I help relax talking about one
thing respectfully you know as a comic
you want to do the comic you want to do
the comical in comic you know I'm
starting to family offices and I'll
explain to you later what that is you
know asset management minimizing tax
exposure and legal exposure for high-end
families I do
publishing I just launched a book in
print for myself and kiss
so it's pop culture I do corporate
speaking so I do a lot of stuff out
playing a band but I've also got a side
band the gene Simmons man which is run a
South America and Japan and my hand is
waving in front of my face for no
particular reason
those guys are great I know those guys
you're back in man yer solo band those
guys are amazing Nashville yeah yeah
very good and they love getting up on
stage so the idea that a day goes by
look let me ask you something so you got
24 hours left of life God secretly told
you what are you gonna do watch I Love
Lucy reruns or binge watch something and
then die are you gonna do I don't think
you'd enjoy my answer but I'm gonna do
for the next 24 hours I sit by the beach
and do nothing it's gonna be binge
watching but his right hand will be busy
my left hand please answer the question
what am I gonna do that's a really tough
question it depends if I would have
access to the girl I'm dating I might
want to spend it with her if I could get
onstage I might want to go up on stage
good that's that's inert I want to do
something you want to give them if your
body stands still your body goes soft
use it or lose it and then your heart
does and you die in the end does not
it's not designed us or water by the way
running water is the healthiest water if
it stays still it gets rotten and stuff
so you got to keep moving we're at life
as we know it are like sharks and the
water you'll have to keep moving even to
just to force the water through your
guilt so you can get oxygen sharks drown
did you know that yeah if they stopped
if they stopped moving they died we got
long as though you they do too but they
have to keep forcing the water through
their lungs to keep moving but in
movement itself is important you know
you put a gerbil in a cage not up your
ass nobody's trying to there's no
predators it gets plenty to eat but give
it a goddamn wheel so it can go around
and keep moving do something yeah you're
alive you have to keep moving so the
idea of vacation is like a bad version
of death so means that your family wants
you to go on vacation with the answer's
no nice no just awayand stop cool I'll
buy Hawaii you go do whatever you want I
have a question for you too about your
topic like as you you get your 68 and as
you move on in life
watched a lot of your interviews
recently so I wanted to know this you
seem like you've changed a little bit
you are you more emotional now oh yeah
then you were and like I watched you in
the Dan Rather interview I've watched
you talking about a lot of things and
you seem to get really moved very easily
and is that something that you always
kind of kept private from people or has
it kind of happened more as you've
gotten older and seen your family
growing odd stuff the answer is yes to
everything because when we're sort of
trained that way you know we're boy the
male of the species you step on a girl's
thing where you've hurt her feelings she
starts to cry so they're very open with
their emotions we got hurt too but the
guys next to us could kind of enhance
wrong with you so you build up that
armor and we always try to be tougher
you know enough pain doesn't hurt us and
words don't hurt us and stuff like that
and then when you become a man you know
more and more as you get older I think
you get to be your true self when you're
the closer you are to death the more
easy the emotions ring true and when
they ring true you know at that point
you don't care so I'm 68 I didn't really
start to open up to myself until I
revisited Israel and went to my father's
grave who sadly I never visited when he
died I was too arrogant and selfish and
all that and Shannon you know who I've
been with for 35 years
I mean look guys are [ __ ] me too
I've been arrogant and selfish and where
are you going where am I going
[ __ ] who wants to know all that stuff
and at 62 I decided to get married for
the first time in my life we have two
great kids and all that stuff guys are
not nice we are we are not designed it
seems to be loving and caring look at
how many fathers run away from their
family and just abandon them and some of
our you know brother and brethren other
cultures and stuff single families are
rampant 80% of males don't exist in some
cultures 80 percent that means women are
left holding the bag they've got to
raise the kids do all that so when I
hear my mother talking who survived Nazi
Germany at age 14 in the concentration
camps and I hear Mike
it's talking and yeah when I see the red
white and blue yeah when I see that I
get choked up
absolutely I've said this about you
before Europe you know you're a real
Patriot like I've seen very few people
in public life who are comfortably and
lovingly talk about America the way you
do you you really love this country
could you not you know as a
first-generation immigrant legal I have
to say because there's a difference
there are more illegal immigrants in
America than there are most people than
there are people men women and children
in most of the countries on planet Earth
is that a statistic that's shocking yeah
actually it is and I mean if they were
from Sweden I guess you couldn't say
racist right but right America was still
under the law safe we got a deport you
because you're here Lee illegally so I'm
uh don't get me started on that by the
way the the I'll bring up the wall
people are arguing up and down and it's
AI think the president is gonna build a
wall whether we like it or not some
people like it some people don't
our wonderful Pope if you're Roman
Catholic or not the Pope's a great guy
and he I think perhaps emotionally came
out against it said this is inhumane
stuff and all that except for the fact
that the Vatican has a huge wall all
right so it's good for the Vatican but
not good for America but actually walls
work yeah they do they always have for
good reasons and bad reasons the Mongols
were stopped for a thousand years even
the Berlin Wall the bad guys built a
wall with East Germans couldn't get out
there's a war between Palestine and
Israel and it actually works it does it
may not be humane maybe it's feelings
are hurt but it worked what you think of
the idea that the symbolism of it is
against America's message of give me
your tired your widows bah-bah-bah it is
it's against that it is but I don't
think you know once upon a time a penny
saved is a penny earned actually meant
something but it is not true today that
was Benjamin Franklin mm-hmm I was a 6th
grade teacher it is untrue today because
that phrase was created
and we didn't have taxes know that he
saved his two pennies earned at the
taught at the highest tax bracket you've
got her and twice as much to wind up
with a penny so you know a lot of those
things and also we're told that the by
the Ten Commandment says do not kill it
actually doesn't say that you know I
speak Hebrew I'm from the land of the
people who gave you the book in the
first place the Bible it actually says
do not murder with main main difference
between that is you're enough do not
murder means something do not kill means
you can't have cops you can't kill
somebody right trying to kill your
children stuff like that I used to I
want you to you still speaking Mandarin
Chinese I never had you were trying but
I wanted to you know
Nihon say say and all that very
difficult it is right John Cena can do
it oh yeah Kenny okay yeah I feel like a
man now what were you feeling
gender-fluid I want to ask about the
about the vote where did this news of
this the $50,000 thing that happened at
all
no it does exist but people
misunderstand here's the bottom line
I will fly a my dime with the insurance
and the lawyers and it's my cost cuz
I've done well in life and I will hand
deliver the largest box set of all time
into your sweaty paws no matter where
you're from we got to find you know the
right time and convenient and all that
stuff that's statement of fact then
there are other ways that you can get
involved if you want special you know
items for today we're gonna be at
Electric Lady studios with somebody who
wants to be part of the producer
experience producer experience is you
sit with me privately and we do focus I
play you the entire 150 songs or as many
as you can get through because it'll
take you know over 12 hours straight of
without bathroom break or anything it's
a lot of music and you may not like a
song move it to this or the fades too
long and stuff like that so I listen to
what executive producers say and then
you get your name in the box set yeah
name is actually engraved in there for
all the units that are going out that's
the
producer experience you can plug that
you can press that button that's 25k
there's only gonna be a handful of
people you're gonna do that and what if
he messes up a song what if you you
think the song is perfect and some guys
like no I think it should be about it
there will be more than one executive
producers and I'll listen to them the
same way that Spielberg does a focus
group and they tell him you know there
could be a hundred people saying I don't
like the end to make it happy and since
at he makes it happy you listen to the
bosses because I may not you know I'm
too close to it I've been close to it
for 50 years and here's the $50,000 one
you know when I was a kid I couldn't ask
Paul McCartney to come over a matter of
fact I'm gonna go see him tonight oh
we're playing a gig you mean no we're
gonna hang out and have some jello put
it no is that the girl okay
have you ever hung out with them yeah
and were you awed by him when you met
him oh yeah you are a real gentleman
it's interesting when you become you
know the gods that walk the earth and
you have the humility and humbleness to
walk up to you know the guy opening
there and say hey are you doing nice to
see just normal stuff yes for one second
did you it did you ever meet Chuck Berry
I saw your eulogy of him which was
really beautiful but did you did you
talk to him and tell him how you felt
about him oh yeah oh that's nice you did
get that you know but if it wasn't for
Chuck there'd be no electric guitar and
stuff he was the guy right stones and
everybody else
Hendrix everybody and when I went to his
funeral they asked me the family asked
me to do the eulogy I didn't prepare
anything I just got all choked up
because chuck is literally right in
front of me in the open casket with the
guitar on there and there wasn't a
single other rocker from any level
nobody I was you know you kidding the
message just came in from Paul McCartney
from Bill Clinton everybody else nobody
was there and I was shocked I didn't I
when I saw that clip I assumed that gene
was one of ten guys that would not I
don't know nobody so when you first met
him will you at least did he know who
you were and did you thank him for all
here that's always a nice thing you
could say that to somebody you know I
mumbled because your ha ha Manama it's
like well Cramton when he talks to
Norton you know yeah
now yeah you're just the amazing amazing
history because when Chuck started it
was race music you couldn't even hear
the music on white radio they were
people don't know that that wasn't a
long time ago right and so rock and roll
wouldn't have been here without Chuck
Little Richard Fats Domino you know the
guys that invented it really and took it
from before them did you ever see some
of the internet videos with Chuck Berry
yeah he had I know the stories and the
stuff but you want to talk to chuck
about certain things and he and I would
have connected on others without sin but
sure here's here's the $50,000 one so
yes Mike you know and that the Beatles
came out they and I love the band and I
bought the records but you know they
were far away it was a record company or
a store that would give it to you so
there was no connection I couldn't dream
of Paul McCartney coming to my house or
hanging out at the bingo hall with me
and with 20 of my closest friends so I
wanted to change that before the kiss
thing stops and before I get off the
road and while I still have a hair left
on my head and lots more on my back now
you can have a gene Simmons home
experience I'll come to your home I'll
hang out with you pet the dog or mount
the dog in front of your children of
course and karaoke schmeyer yogi you
decide what the party's gonna be but
it's a gene Simmons party at your home
you take care of everything else I'll
fly in at my dime and you know ensure
the right thing and all that and
nothing's cheap and it's all expensive
for me too if I'm going to New Zealand
to go to a party but I'm not gonna make
it a dime but yeah before this is
through I've got to do this for me
thanking the fans for making my goddamn
life possible because if they weren't
here I'd be asking the next person in
line would you like some fries with that
you know when you get the keys to the
kingdom and you're clear
some little fifteen-year-old kid gave it
to you who's now 40 and 50 years old
don't you want to go up and grab them by
the shows and say you don't know what
you've what you've meant to me and my
family and and through you I've been
able to create
jobs and do other things and gift of
philanthropy you're the ones that did
this so that's what I'm gonna do and you
see here shows too it's like parents
will bring their their children so it's
a good really crazy given to me when you
think it do you ever do you ever worry
or or or get creeped out by stories that
fans tell you about just about about how
much you or kiss means to them well yeah
because every sometimes it goes the word
fan comes from the word fanatic and you
know in the early days of girls showing
you know before AIDS I remember one
story very quickly yeah knock on the
door I look through its Indianapolis I
happen to remember because I've never
been higher drunk and I I've got my
towel around me because they just came
out of the show you really can't come in
I've got to catch an early morning fly
it on it please and she's cute so I'm
going what the hell yeah I can't you be
nice to somebody so she comes in I said
you can't stay long I've got to get up 6
a.m. or whatever oh don't worry and so
you know boom boom wham bam and all that
and so when it's time going it was
lovely to have seen you and I look
forward to seeing you again whatever
your name is and I hope to see you again
good night and she gets up and she's got
a slave bracelet around her thing they
used to call it that jewelry around her
waist can I show you something before I
go yeah sure so she takes out a little
Persian carpet puts it on the floor you
know about four feet long and takes out
these little candelabras and lights
candles oh I'm just gonna do a handstand
or something so I propped myself up to
see it and then she gets on her knees
all naked and goes Oh Prince of Darkness
what would you have me do and I'm just
y-yeah hahaha well so I couldn't think
of anything I'm telling you the truth so
I said first thing you can't do I might
go up to where the roadies are they're
having a party and drinking and whatever
on the 14th floor you'll find the room
and blow everybody you know whatever I'm
saying so I didn't hear anything about
it I went to sleep got up
the next day we're in Terre Haute
Indiana see what I mean yeah aren't
owned by the Holman George family who
went on to form the Indy car thing and
which I became the marketing director
for and I go to the show and usually the
roadies of stand office they've got work
to do in their dog-tired not that day
everybody Jean can I get you a glass of
water anything you yeah apparently she
did what her masters what a good guy you
are
how many roadies you think she went
through ten I think my guess I wasn't
there I would imagine anybody that was
in the room that's amazing that that's
what that's just a trooper just like a
man you know can you take care of my
friends Lord of Darkness oh no god it's
a little darker than that well yeah but
still yeah but you could have said give
me a ride to the airport she said give
me a wish you could have said I gotta go
to the airport hours you shared it you
said don't take care to guys I feel
better now Jim actually has a really fun
story about a dream he used to have
about kiss as a kid it's not a fun story
sexual no no no I was seven it wasn't
even I don't want to tell is
embarrassing you know they made me tell
Paul one times that it was no no you
wanted to tell it
no I didn't oh my mistake when I was a
kid this is true when I was seven years
old I were eight years old I had a
really weird kiss daydream it was so
bizarre that I thought that kiss would
show up to my house and full makeup and
costumes I met you guys would beat me up
and hurt me and throw me down the steps
and then and then hug me and love me and
make me feel all of you know hug there
was no sexual I didn't have sexual
thoughts
it was later then the band would gather
around and make me feel better and give
me hugs
well Jean will do it for like 30 grand
throw me down the stairs and then hug me
and kiss my stick kicking around the
wrist for I have similar dreams with The
Beatles literally and Jackson Heights no
hitting if I'm much bigger than they are
but I thought I was one of the Beatles I
had the shag you know the haircut yeah
somehow I didn't think there was a size
difference you know because I tower
among the
there five eight five seven something
and this was around sixty five and I
became an enormous Beatle fan and thirty
thirty seventh Avenue in Jackson Heights
and stuff we're running down because
just like hard day's night the girls are
after us and stuffing we would run into
a record company and I remember it like
it was yesterday and then run up the
stairs to the L the elevated train
station and because the girls didn't
have tokens to get in we were safe I
have no idea what the dream meant but I
was somehow now there was five Beatles
yeah it's weird right well it wasn't it
was a little weirder - we were always
always awake when I did it but it wasn't
he wanted kiss to beat him up and then
hug him and stuff can be arranged - two
quick questions - they both are just
kind of fanboy questions one is I told
you I almost went to the rock I almost
canceled a big money gig to go to the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame induction to
get a photo with the original four
members but I didn't know if I'd get
back and I just couldn't do it will
there ever be another opportunity to get
all four of you in the room playing or
not
doing something else just you mean to be
in the room together sure to get a photo
at the for you Peter G you peter
polonaise yep and Mary yeah sure why not
in fact ace is gonna jump up on stage
I'm doing a on September 20th hurricane
relief for the poor people in Houston
it's gonna be in many Minneapolis st.
Paul people can go to the children
matter dot NGO it's an organ it's a
charity I created along with mater which
is a Midwestern charity and so all the
proceeds are going to hurricane relief
it's gonna be the gene Simmons band and
Don Felder cheap trick Jayhawks and ace
called and said can I please join up
there and so yeah she's gonna jam some
songs oh yeah and you just wrote two
songs with ace first I did he called me
up and wanted some help on his new
record couldn't come up I don't know
what whatever he was looking for I was
happy to run out to the desert where he
lived and we came up with two really
good song I wanted to take you to get
back into the sync of collaborating with
someone that you haven't collaborated
with in so long like if you get just
kind of
back into it what what you have to do I
think the yes the answer is yes by just
being yourself and doing what you like
but you just start going and see if some
if something kicks off with somebody I
don't want to say it's like riding a
bike
but whatever that thing was I mean I can
write a song if you have a guitar here
I'll write a song in two minutes it may
not be a good song right but the idea of
create listen everybody is musical
everybody goes in the shower even if
it's not in tune it goes mm-hmm and you
start making up your own melodies
everybody's musical human beings are you
alright melodies and songs and you all
do rhymes and stuff but you know the
rappers you know just free-flowing
they're creating you know lyrics there's
no music involved in it but that's
another story so but everybody hums in
the shower sure you're a rap guy you
like that music it does not speak to me
culturally I don't I don't want to
pretend that I understand it because I
didn't grow up in the ghetto however you
have to respect it as a form of art I
mean I can go to opera and just really
be admire the entire thing of it
although I don't go into the car and put
on but to reach you like jazz doesn't
reach me no jazz doesn't do anything for
me it just crazy music what's that crazy
music you know yesterday right and also
this is this is probably not the and
I'll pay for this I'm not asking for
anything for free where can I get mint
condition copies of the four original
chopper posters that's what I want I
went on Twitter I've been on ebay I have
shitty copies of them I want four
mint-condition copy I mean one of these
there are and in Israel it's I gevalt
there are fan sites one is called
everything kiss and some other stuff for
the fans just trade with themselves and
we have 5000 licensed products literally
everything from and you know what's
coming everything from kiss condoms to
kiss caskets will get you coming and
we'll get you guys that's pretty funny
and then and but that's go to the kid
one of the kids fansite
you can go to any one of the kiss Kansai
and just ask them here's what I'm
looking for because they're fans coming
from the word fanatic they'll tell you
it go here go here and before I leave I
should mention that the largest box set
of all time only a few thousand are
gonna be made they're all be gone this
month my assumption is January 1st is
when I start flying around the world and
delivering them because every single one
is gonna be hand-delivered by me to the
fans that buy them and we get to keep
this one even the $2,000 but you could
actually buy that for Christmas for
somebody if you you buy that for your
husband or your brother is a great kiss
fan and you buy that or you get in with
a few people no whoa and gene shows up
that's pretty amazing what happen is
that you what happens if there's 25 guys
big fans they're all drunk and you show
up at the house and they're obnoxious as
I've seen you around drunk people you're
not too happy what do you do there you
have to spend two hours when I and can I
get back to you on that and they're very
obnoxious I am NOT happy because
everybody's got an excuse oh I'm sorry I
threw up on your shoes I was drunk I'm
sorry I threw you off the building I was
straight I I'm not a fan of anybody by
the way here allowed to drink and all
that stuff but whatever you behave
whatever behavior that happens while
you're drunk your response you don't
like the loss of control
personal responsibility no you can lose
control but whatever you do whether
you're in control or not that's your
responsibility and there should be
repercussions you kill somebody while
you're drunk if sure if I'm in charge
death